première scène est de retour pour une
quatrième édition ce tremplin de
musiques pour les jeunes lycéens d'île
de france est organisé par le festival
rock en seine célia gars de son go vous
êtes avec nous sur ce plateau bonsoir
bonsoir et vous allez nous en parler
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut gagner déjà en
participant à ce concours
et bien tout simplement de pouvoir
rejouer en live au festival rock en
seine qui aura lieu le 27 28 et 29 août
alors tous les départements de la région
sont concernés ce qui représente environ
240 au lycée et touche plus de cent
cinquante mille lycéens la région
ile-de-france a est partenaire du
festival
l'objectif c'est vraiment donné scène
accès à la culture aux anneaux lycéens
et puis de découvrir et donc celle ya
combien de groupes vont pouvoir se
produire hier ce seront six groupes de
musique qui auront à la possibilité
d'une première expérience sur une grande
scène et aussi d'une bonne visibilité
le fait de pouvoir exercer montré entre
guillemets son talent sur scène permet
aussi à ces jeunes de découvrir d'autres
artistes et d'échangés qui c'est aussi
de pouvoir continuer d'être aperçue par
les professionnels les groupes de
musique lycéens pourront également
visiter les backstage rencontrer les
professionnels et participer à des
ateliers collaboratif mais avant tout
cela célia il faudra donc gagné le
tremplin
oui et c'est donc que la maison des
jeunes et de la culture les terrasses
des eaux de conflans sainte honorine qui
se charge de l'organisation
pour le département des yvelines alors
les inscriptions sont ouvertes depuis
lundi 11 janvier et la finale aura lieu
en mai lors du festival bonne machine
qui se tient dans le parc de la mjc sous
chapiteau tous les styles de groupes
musicaux que ce soit rap électro ou
encore reggae elles sont acceptées après
le tremplin une poule le gagnant du
tremplin de 78 noms met en place un
accompagnement et un coaching d'euros
pour qu'il soit prêt quand même pour
passer sur la scène de rock en seine fin
à ce que c'est pas une petite scène
alors pour s'inscrire il suffit d'avoir
moins de 21 ans et que la moitié des
musiciens du groupe soit encore au lycée
et puis ensuite se rendre sur le site
internet ww pour un premier tir est
saine
merci célia pour ces précisions et bien
entendu le festival aura lieu sous
réserve de l'évolution des conditions
sanitaires qui bien sûr